hey guys I'm a - art welcome to Abby's
kitchen and our brand new series though
Ridiculist yes we're taking a cue from
our favorite Silver Fox mister Anderson
Cooper because there is so much out
there on the internet that I need to
talk about I just got to get these words
these feelings these angers out of me
just BAM out so let's get right to it
first up on the Ridiculist is dr.
gingers coconut toothpaste you can
purchase this on Urban Outfitters calm
which is honestly a treasure trove of
[ __ ]
this retails for $14 for toothpaste guys
I can get it for like a buck at the
drugstore I mean I mean not this one but
like a legitimate toothpaste that
actually cleans your teeth but this one
promises to have a coconut mint flavor
it boosts gum health it freshens breath
it whiten teeth without any harsh
fluoride now let's just talk about
fluoride for a second folks I'm pretty
sure we have fluoride in our toothpaste
and in our water for a reason because it
helps prevent tooth decay so I can't
make a comment on what's gonna happen if
you use a fluoride free toothpaste every
day I'm not a dentist that is outside
the scope of my practice but I can tell
you what is gonna happen if you use a
$14 toothpaste in place of something
that actually is being proven to
legitimately work I don't know you're
probably going to be pissed because
you're throwing your money away and your
teeth are going to rot just saying
please guys don't buy this if you like
coconut and you like that beautiful
coconut flavor I don't know make a curry
that's a great idea right there
coconut milk wham bam thank you ma'am
and then brush your teeth with
toothpaste okay moving on number two
activated charcoal ice cream this is
everywhere and I'm so sick of seeing
people walking around down
town with their little soft-serve in tow
taking that Instagram
guys I've seen it I've seen it a million
times I don't need to see it no more now
let's talk about activated charcoal for
just a hot second here so activated
charcoal has been touted for its detox
properties but that's because it's used
in like clinical settings for literally
stripping your body your gut of any kind
of chemicals or poisons that you ingest
but at the same time it's also going to
absorb and therefore reduce the
absorption of any nutrient set of you've
ingested as well now I'm not saying that
there's a lot of vitamins and minerals
in ice cream that you're not really
gonna get that but any of these supposed
health benefits that are in activated
charcoal ice cream will very quickly be
undone by the fact that you're eating
ice cream now here's a little fun
factoid did you know that in New York
City they have banned the use of
activated charcoal put in food products
um that meant that a lot of ice cream
parlors had to dump their stock very sad
times indeed very sad times so New York
Millennials you're gonna have to go
underground
to get your Instagram fix just saying
alright moving on
alright we're back on the Urban
Outfitters calm web site because guys
this is gold but this one is the Pearl
butter the butter you got to have a
French word in there it doesn't sound
legit adaptogenic coconut butter now
this container of coconut butter is
selling for $29 for something that
honestly looks like a melted candle in
all honesty there's different colors
here and different flavors depending on
what it touts that it's supposed to do
so let's take a look-see shall we so we
have the dirty detox of course there's
got to be a detox version this one is
black it has has smaller that activated
charcoal in it honestly who the [ __ ]
wants to poke black on their toast it
looks like a squid like squid ink just
kind of exploded on on your piece of
your nice little piece of bread
we've got the beauty butter the beauty
butter is pink so you know that's always
pretty and then we have the the what
else we got here the glow getter these
are such such cute little names I think
glow getter that has turmeric in it so
it's obviously anti-inflammatory mmm-hmm
and then the smarty pants suit that's
cute
the smarty pants you apparently boosts
brain health and that's because it's got
spirulina in it and it makes it blue and
it looks like a smurf just took a big
dump on your dosed so that's great it
kind of grosses yeah I mean when you
guys see this you're just going to Ralph
honestly I would not recommend putting
this on your breakfast toast coconut
butter in general is super Hari now and
I've got no qualms about using coconut
oil and my recipes but the fact that
you're spending twenty nine dollars to
do this especially because none of these
claims are FDA approved it says so right
here on the website so please don't
believe the hype you're not going to
like become smarter just by putting some
this blue on your toast that just sounds
like something that came up with in the
90s and got rid of really fast
uh that's a note from me next
so the gummy bear cleanse so I looked
into this one and apparently this was
actually done by a company called
sugarfina as a prank but a lot of people
were like really psyched about the idea
of having some kind of green juice
cleansing gummy bear situation because
hey who doesn't want to eat candy all
day and get their body cleansed but
first things first folks let's go on and
talk about the cleanse situation guys
you don't need an cleanse or detox to
get healthy because your body assuming
it is in tip-top shape your body does
this every single day all day through
the fact that you're just taking you're
going pee you're sweating you're
breathing congratulations you are
cleansing all day air day and you don't
need a gummy bear to do it now there's a
lot of gummy bear products out there
that I've seen and I think it's really
funny because there's there's a lot of
sugar
three ones that basically have a
laxative effect so I guess you could say
it's a cleanse because everything's
gonna come out of you and then there's
some kind of fat-burning gummies that
I've seen on the market that are packed
with things like caffeine now yes
caffeine in large amounts have small
impacts on your metabolism but that
doesn't necessarily mean that it's a
healthy thing to eat not to mention it
is way better to be getting your
vitamins your minerals and everything
else from real fruits and vegetables
rather than candy masquerading as some
kind of health food so guys skip the
gummies skip the cleanse in general and
just eat real food okay and finally the
flat tummy lollipops so I've seen this
come up a million times in my Instagram
feed and my Facebook feed I'm getting
annoyed with Facebook because hey why
are you sending me that but I know it's
become really popular because people
like Kim Kardashian not being using them
using them right and everyone wants to
look like Kim K but here's a little
little insider secret Kim K doesn't look
the way she does because she's eating
lollipops all day Kim K has access to a
world of personal trainers and
nutritionists and dieticians and meal
plans and she doesn't have to do [ __ ]
never mind suck on a lollipop it's not
some kind of magic pill the reality is
we don't have any legitimate research to
suggest that these products these diet
products are safe
never mind that they work even if the
label says it's clinically proven folks
there is not any quality research out
there to suggest that it is so skip the
lollipops I say and instead try to focus
on ending really good quality foods that
you actually truly enjoy so guys I hope
you enjoyed this video if you did be
sure to give it the thumbs up leave me a
comment below with some of the most
outrageous things that you've seen on
the internet that you would like to see
me talk about on the next ridiculous
subscribe to the channel and I'll see
you next time on Abby's kitchen bye
[Music]